previously on grave hoppers the show
where we here at GameSpot put permadeath
in every game I don't know if I'm ready
for this also be sure to pick up several
golden claymores that are lying around
before you face Ganon oh god oh god it's
all the time yeah you like it
look at you you love it
oh hey you and every one of your family
mother
he is just not dying there we go oh yeah
you're about to show me your tongue nice
that one better than it could have but I
kind of wanted to kick their ass
shield deflect god no okay I've seen you
do it you got the timing down oh nice
[Music]
Jesus you know the other part about
Master mode is that it's unpredictable
they have or they'll have like a second
fire I swear to God like sometimes you
can't predict it yeah it's messed up
maybe it's just the walkers
Oh see what I mean it's different that's
not right yeah that was not right that
was off he waited yeah he waited that's
not cool
just go away god oh my god
this is like when a murderer is chasing
someone they're trying to get the key in
the door all right I'm out of here I'm
out of here I'm out of here I gotta cook
some shot I come so far
Judy's machine-gunning you in this this
guy worried if I if I have my ear up my
shots right yeah and that should be good
hey everyone welcome back to great
hoppers the show where we put permadeath
in every game I'm like my Hardy hi I'm
Rob it was all foes yeah you just saw
the previously last week's antics that
was a lot of some good stuff killing
some Guardians which that's kind of the
plan today I think I'll let you walk
people through that in a second but uh
these are my notes
we're back to grape hoppers everything I
could possibly I've said this a few
times but I mean I guess any episode
could be the last episode if you're new
or if you're just to catch you up if Rob
gets through an hour of Zelda breath of
the wild today we'll keep playing next
week but that might be tough this week
we got a few things planned but if he
dies at any point for any reason we move
on to Metal Gear Solid 5 I'm gonna start
with Ground zeroes I have that queued up
in case let's see what happens I forgot
to make the list whatever we'll just
show it I'll change it for next time
I suck this is not this is about this is
basically like four hours four hours
yeah
that's what we have next as Metal Gear
and then alien eyes yeah so that's the
that's the current list we've got like
probably 12 more games that people have
been recommending a lot that we'll get
into so that's not really yeah that's it
remains to be seen but yeah so what is
what is the plan for this week you're
gonna go garnish oh you need Coors for
this you want the stasis to get the
Hylian Shield to go fly cannon right you
are so I need like three
shafts three screws you're good there
yeah I need those three [ __ ] regular
cores and so I think the best the best
way to get those is from Guardian
walkers luckily as we left off I've to
engineer a second I could three three
yeah one unless it to so I could
probably kill three walkers if I don't
blow it
yeah you got a bunch of arrows last time
you got bomb arrows you got ice arrows
or maybe those two episodes ago I can't
member but you have a decent like ver
active yeah
elemental attacks indeed alright so
let's just do just that so I think we're
gonna go warp out of this met [ __ ]
oh there's a start kind of counting down
now so an hour from now 527 you're my
time right now when we're recording this
okay survive till then or else I'm
jumping into snakes boots I'm gonna cook
baby oh yeah this is a right behind that
dude that gave you some trouble left I
had my nemesis that goddamn was alph Oh
endless reservoir of saliva should be
able to do this right yeah that worked
out yeah no no no you just shoot the the
logs not the pot this was a good tip
well can you read that
dang yeah I can if you're cooking for
more yellow hearts you need to put more
of the affecting ingredients in non
effective ingredients only help your red
hearts putting meat and apples with one
durian is going to give minimum yellow
hearts because of the minimum minimal
affecting ingredients with more red
because of the random other stuff thank
you uh yo somebody Sam so yeah his point
being that you know there's the the
keywords and all the cooking ingredients
right there's my tea there's like Hardy
or not Hardy that would not be one yeah
point being that like if I'm using say
if like I did a like a mighty thistle
and an apple I'm all the Apple does is
just give me more hearts so I want to
have like effects so mighty banana is my
fissile I don't think I have anything
else I thought I had
room maybe but I don't know sort this
does they should just give me some more
attack power yeah I mean for the most
part yeah that's that's pretty good okay
and like I don't really have much to
work with here
freaking chicken dish Apple I shouldn't
have done that I think about it because
it doesn't have the opposite was
Yosemite Sam said well I don't need
should just kick them cook them
separately cuz it's just all its gonna
do is go very hard ten hearts I don't
have ten hearts so that was kind of dumb
I see what you're saying you're it's
like diminishing returns you might as
well eat them separately right like not
combining herbs and Raziel or something
right I think that's probably good for
now where are you gonna go look for
guardians in a kala or just around
Hyrule Castle yeah I might just go for a
Hyrule Castle
seven that's good okay man so I like
was getting a thumbnail for last show
and there's two was alphas in here with
a lot of good oh yeah wait what do they
have you want to do a hit and run with
some electric stuff it's not what they
have
it's what's Athena actually down here Oh
madlyn he's got a good sword that might
be worth you got an electric arrow I'm
getting out of here it's the Royal one
right not Royal Guards but I can't so
here's the thing as I can all right well
okay that's fair do this oh there's a
claymore on the Statue behind him - yeah
- thanks
it I don't think you saw you Oh God oh
so that's how the it's happening all
over again that's how the endurance
works with additional endurance
it's like limited quantity yeah gotcha I
never use those yeah well I guess I
wouldn't by the time I know they're so
persist are you going back down oh it's
a different door
dude this is happening all over again
like you planned it no he's gone yeah
get out of here stop risking it you got
two good weapons though I'm sorry oh god
that was worth it you think I'd be used
to it by now
so looking for how many cores three yeah
you know that for sure
or is that don't worry I don't the drop
okay can I look it up or just so you're
not like hunting them for no reason and
risking your life or you would you know
I am that's that's probably the bet this
is the best way to do it is to is to
kill these no I mean like but you do
know you you're positive you need three
of those cores oh for sure yeah okay now
that I you continually proven your
memory this game is good I just it would
be shitty if you risked your life for an
hour and then you found out you already
had the ingredients yeah no no it's for
sure so that the the thing is is that
and I might be just thinking of there's
there's great what they called me
there's basically two types of course oh
there's like giant OS what is its giant
ancient core and then ancient core I
just need a in course giant ancient
chords are more rare as far as the drop
gotcha
so like can I grab that mouse yeah are
the giant ancient cores are those from
like the mighty test of strength or
whatever
[Music]
you pin one of a couple the sometimes so
you can get them sometimes there's a
chest that'll have it okay hey there boy
you a lot of rural garden equipment
actually shield bow in and a halberd and
a sword Wow my stuff breaks pretty easy
though the one I didn't know their
durability was lower yeah I didn't know
that until today actually I somehow I
mean YouTube knows what I like and so I
stumbled on a video that was a guy
saying that like the best the best like
weapons in the game are like the
Lionel's gear and the Lionel gear last
variants like the best balance between
damage and durability yeah I mean
they're even like better like the higher
damage but that's probably not worth
trying to get all right I mean like if
you electrocute one and then grab his
stuff and then go no cuz they are
resistant to helman all right while
you're riding oh Jesus but stall while
you're riding odd got a we got a welcome
to the breath of the wild playthrough
they have canceled grave hoppers this
smiley frog yeah he's he's eagerly
awaiting your death Rob he or she is a
healer waiting your demise
oh wait I wasn't thinking straight I
want to equip this for might be coming
yeah I might be coming are you gonna
stay on but Stalin shroom no I'm gonna
bulb off right ooh a couple of bow cobs
thanks simple
oh great so you're hoping for a core to
drop right yeah I am he's key sir
still decent Oh still a decent was oh
there's a lot of them
what's all that was that way was that
two fairies
no did that second dude Rahu is one but
that the second dude hit you with his
sword too I thought I'd drained you
twice oh my totally dead you're right he
didn't even lay your get back dude oh my
god you're right urine this is not good
you got it dude yeah eat something that
was such [ __ ] but still we're up you
couldn't hear me
I'm panicking
yeah oh my god Oh sick where have you
been where have you been
Oh God this horse is such a dumb [ __ ]
why is he nutty look at him he's just
hanging out you need fairies too
you wrote that down little do we know
that would foreshadow what's to come
yeah you know where I should have put it
oh it was first oh my god my fairies my
heart and we'll probably can't read that
but it says fairies number one dude that
is so crazy that cuz it okay so I saw
that little like blip of a fairy
I was like did that just use a second
one before you even got up do you even
notice that yeah I haven't so quickly
man my right side you got some some
materials not to what you needed but
some in case you wanna maybe buy arrows
or something I'm not sure well I got a
lot of stuff I could sell to what could
you buy or what would you need to buy
armor yeah we could all go for a bite
and do this oh my god my heart I panic
so bad there smiley frog almost guys
wish I can't believe that believe it who
and who would have thought I've been
freaking Bo cobbling Zhaan well the
electric arrows were definitely a pain
yeah yeah you got a little cocky I did
yeah like ardian was what smoothly I
mean I knew those guys were there I
thought I could like pull it off and get
out
Oh betul betul betul damn speak to
grande roue would you get the diamonds
um I had we've gone in the castle
I love once you do Tarrytown
you got the Goron you just sell to him
the whole time yeah is that right
Tarrytown yeah Oh God yeah makes Bank
here
was there any armor I needed I guess it
was all just about excuse me about
upgrading it I mean you could get
something better than the champions
tunic probably I'm the champion chance
pretty good yes upgrade I can't remember
what else I need upgrade we can check
with the see what the ferry where is it
would it even matter though if you
upgrade it with this many hearts I guess
if you're eating something oh wait I
need to find another ferry in order to
get to a level two because that's the
whole point of getting more ferry
fountains is like we need to have them
all in order to get a piece of armor up
to four levels you got the one in the
kala
that's what Guardians there there's the
one there yeah that'd probably be the
easiest man that was real close I don't
think it's ever been that close before
yeah yeah you had fairies all the other
times
just kidding that's good too right
and everyone in the goddamn freaking
Newcastle oh yeah I mean more weapons
but f my [ __ ] my boys back my nemesis
great it's not frustration therapy
fairies here
god damnit where the do they not
replenish they do
oh maybe all I boon yeah maybe I'll get
out of here I'm the first time this
happened like I know you but I
definitely like [ __ ] myself what do you
think and then the little red flares
because it because it's it's that purple
aesthetic to or it's like it's just like
I remember thing like it's gaining
coming after me yeah I'm coming to you
blink and yeah this music is really
ominous I know okay yeah that's me right
just trying to help you out
this sucks
I mean you have to go to someone who
comments them like that second episode
saying you got to go to another fountain
which we kind of have to anyway right
yeah kind of I think a cowl is the
closest one you just parachute off that
I don't like this then just puts me on
there's my seat yeah I don't have any
backup this is scary so not be the
champions tunic you need a second right
fairy and I would need to kill some
problems oh that's good though actually
because now I can go back here and get
those durians Oh from the from those two
let's alphas oh yeah like you're gonna
have to eat a lot or not get hit or just
go for the durians and get out of there
sail off the cliff once you're done
that's a pretty good idea don't even
bother with them I mean I could just
freakin kill them I might just use like
TM also that that Guardian drop didn't
even have cores that sucks
back for the party I mean I could just
freaking wreck them I got decent amount
of all knows - you have to kill him I
wanted a gonna I mean I just want to I
don't want to I don't want to like worry
about this nope
I'll have my well nevermind was a lot of
did that cook the durians uh there was
just one in here oh I thought those
going green things were those are just
ferns I shouldn't have thought I can't
claim what I would use it oh wait I'll
just use your head precious head like an
idiot good I feel like I'm having an off
day these guys
what do restless crickets do the stamina
of some sort
I just replenishes your stamina so it's
not enduring which I believe enduring
would enduring is what gives me extra
time when I do that I don't know where
it flew freshest durians
there are a lot of here cuz you're not
just climb the tree and grab the durian
I could drag on if you're not gonna use
weapon anyway might as well speed it up
no he's gonna let you die hate you
so you're going to the ferry next right
yeah I'm gonna go too
okay so potato that's like up here so
buff Kakariko so I'll go no colwiz like
up there right yeah it's like around
here huh it's near the tower so it's
right near that is that the Farah
Collett hour north of Kakariko no oh
it's a shrine what do I have to travel
through I think it's like a forest I
mean I want to get my horse my
stupid-ass horse mm-hmm and I'll just
Trek cuz I remember just spawning into
the Acala tower and then jumping off and
floating over to the ferry yeah yeah
there's the tower is hard to get to you
have to cut there's all these flying
guardians around it
oh it's now you can leap off as auras
domain but like even getting there is
tough he's in zora's domain south of you
know it's north it's like it's south of
the dude I don't
the worst was when I really screwed up
and I was like gold but stolen I
freaking pushed him to the limit kicked
me off yeah I was dumb he got his
revenge oh you got just enough to make
two meals
Oh should I split these up do like two
and three wish I do yeah probably you
already got a full-on eight there's
pretty good I have these guys cook them
with I screw this up
what are you making I remember like some
of these are like really potent this
kind what the hell are you making you're
ruining the pot okay so going north
right to the it's a college to the east
of Death Mountain yeah is it up here
it's like pretty far northeast the bond
of this thing is that was quite a lot I
went to that one girl who like checks
your bond she'd be like I'm taking this
horse I work for the FBI yeah what
what's up with these bruises this horse
is mine now get out of here you [ __ ]
monster
not really paying attention to any of
these row ads
[Music]
you knows much huh you see them they're
better than you all of them where is a
Down Guardian oh there's one to your
left at two isn't it
there's that tree that was a tree
nevermind I'm bound to hit a bridge so
I'll just keep going
no fairies chill baby I'd be skittish if
I was him to go in the water yeah
uses guts though oh yeah give me
something good
[Music]
don't it's a lonely party up there whoa
what's tall flexing some tricks speed up
but he does have a brother ginormous ass
oh yeah sorry I know that's my horses
hey he's out of control
he's what we call emotionally
underdeveloped sweet just in case
oh he's here too I always thought I
thought he only spawned her like a
couple locations I think oh you talk you
you like use them a couple more times
then he goes to car out of the forest
okay so beetle yeah I mean if you see
death mountains to the east of Death
Mountain what area is this
yeah so it's northeast of here oh that's
it
no that's the that's the this is it is
that's the Acala tower cuz it's like on
that
well yeah you're right walking across
this field yeah guardians
[Music]
damn marry chests there what's different
this thing damn it
am I wrong you might just have to get
another one put in the same nothing's
different
maybe you just need to get another one
put it here here
Oh corner bite by Nick Warrick and get
himself out
bust off you were not an idiot you could
swim maybe what that dude in the water
oh it's a Zora be drowning or I'm bored
as hell been waiting here since episode
one
Oh
oh my god it's poor horse
I am I am definitely afraid it's gonna
die please cross this peace process yes
yeah on YouTube never comment undefined
variable said Rob is to ope oh he needs
to be nerfed oh baby make it play
without his glasses out of fairies but
yeah you're still doing alright you
pulled out calm that comment I've heard
this he's faster than a horse well but
stole anything worthwhile the cheapest
which one you going for that
szura's leave me alone no seriously link
right in front of you dude yeah I see
that's how are there I'm gonna go not
there oh she still tells you Prince sit
on pretty sure your alien man they
really try to get you to go to Toros
domain before they behind beasts which
makes sense but Josh I'll do them in
Reverse desert first first which is like
arguably the hardest yeah every
temperature you have to deal with man it
like makes me
like I say it's gonna put it's gonna
force me on foot I don't know how else I
can like look good
I don't know how else I can get my horse
over there oh Christ no it's gonna make
me get off my horse I think I don't know
how else I can get there it's going foot
yeah so I don't I don't want to go this
way it's gonna take forever oh wow
shocked respect wait did he take any
hearts away I may just you've got that
great
thanks [ __ ] why you're up here once
you have the fair you could go fighting
those uh guardians in the field under
the tower yeah there's a bunch though
you have what two more arrows right now
there's also a guy who sells Guardian
parts in a Taino village but when he
comes is like it's like a real weird
time it's hard to like predict it Oh God
was it a Whizzer oh yeah they're so
creepy
well how you could see like the woods
changing to like conifers and autumn
[ __ ] of course you can't he's deaf
just for your info I've been going about
25 minutes okay there you go Thanks this
rain doesn't help yeah that's the way to
hold out doom right Death Mountain Death
Mountain dang it
yeah I think in Lord of the Rings I am
thinking more rings close enough though
well shared ride this bore
are you going hit a jump just a mess
with you forever he's killed himself so
this one's hard to get to is there like
that evil stuff growing on it
ah do you mean weird hard to get
supersonic cliff it's our cliff and
there are Guardians surrounding it I
mean you can kind of run past them and
there's also guys this might be really
tough
yikes yeah it might be tough I might
have to do some good guys this hill here
yeah I don't know your endurance isn't
crazy how you might have to use like
some food you need to climb a lot yeah I
was a campaign the mob wins a couple of
them folk albums - it's raining - no I
just thought oh no one didn't even
noticed that they like looked up at the
rain that's pretty cool
bye-bye
no chest there we're on this one yeah
ooh nice knocking off yeah yeah yeah
suck it eat it hey how's it taste stop
hitting yourself stop hitting yourself
fall off something good arrows it's
gonna be like a friggin what were you
gonna say
oh great Frost bleep sweet almost there
oh there's some Guardians doubt they're
gonna have Korres but great Just My Luck
oh it's the frost blade stone guess rock
wedding today yeah he's got something
yeah just let him die
what was that
wait at the tower right ahead of you oh
oh hi I need your help give me something
I saved your life
it's sour oh yeah I don't even like
climb this oh wait oh it's this will
help
all right I I know you know this but
just to remind you you don't have any
fairies right now so you don't die
give me your wolf meat Oh Guardian oh
yeah stuff I feel like this is really
stupid oh my god
yeah it'd be quiet about it I wish it
wasn't raining
see look at all these guys
do you definitely need the tower now
that you're up here like I don't think
you need the tower like you're here the
tower was mainly just to get the
teleport point yeah but like I've ever
wanted to come back to this very thumb
true
the rain sucks
these guys suck
Oh use that box against the right this
sucks
you could just jump the cliff and you
should probably eat something that's
like should I say this sucks this sucks
I didn't like this we should have done
this I mean like I said you could just
cut your losses and jump the cliff and
go to the ferry now she's on the other
side of cliff right
crap it fired that wasn't that bad
oh I have this yellow
back off
this isn't that could have been worse I
coulda been worse but there's gonna be a
couple other ones I mean I'll do my best
to avoid them wait a second I'm not
thinking of the tower I'm thinking oh
it's a shrine Ryan yeah I mean you're
still I forget which one it is though
heyo it's down here so that's the that's
Tarrytown that one it is this one but
sort of the ferry would be here or over
here boys would know okay I agree it's
in a woods next to a shrine but I
thought it was facing that way no you're
right because that's the spiral last
year yeah you're right okay sweet well
that saves you fighting like six more
Guardians for now I don't even know why
yeah I don't even have to go up there
you know you would have had a circum
into cliff anyway that was more exciting
yeah yeah it was it's over here great
now I can be cool again
sup dog oh my god Cooper yeah you better
run these cannons oh god oh god we're my
thing go to
I want my I want my boomerang back
where'd it go what the hell what the
Frick guys I love this
yeah yeah get out of here did he take
the other dudes head yeah
can we get it see ya oh it's three oh
there it is
oh it is facing north okay never mind
I got disorient when you plan to circled
the tower yeah
oh he crossed that I have enough money
in event there's a core rock enough
money for what well I have to she needs
money in order to activate oh yeah like
a donation or ever she says yeah rain
would suck right now yeah oh god what am
i doing you just
what were you trying to do I don't know
thank you oh I thought I could walk up
that I start about drowning
ooh that's a sense my noise oh these
guys really suck yeah just go just jump
that cliff let him go oh yeah you almost
got off that waterfall it's a fast
current ain't it you have like 13 more
minutes oh [ __ ] you might as well get
this shrine right for the teleport oh my
god oh you saw you really didn't ask
always a white one too oh yeah oh no
he's still here you need to stop firing
that's a fast Jesus machine gun oh is
that it agreed coming he's not a white
one at least
screw that you're so close to more
fairies oh he saw you just so you know
he's coming by a but good night oh there
are at least one two two three
daddy like come here you little ferret
Oh even that just makes me feel better
yeah nope that's not what I want
No shoot it no just kidding
great good job good job good job good
job good job good job
all right well you got to that's better
than none
God carrots are ugly sometimes wasn't
ask carrot not sweet that's gonna be by
maybe like five no it's gonna be like
200 cuz the last oh no the last ones
like ten thousand yeah five hundred that
make sense there's a thousand and then
it's probably a five thousand yeah sure
here you go you need her for the
champion tunic upgrade right yeah but I
wonder what it what didn't what parts it
needs like I I bet I don't have enough
I'd like to see at least
[Music]
beautiful nice
yeah oh that shard of ferocious horn is
the thing what about that dragon is I
hope freakin electrocute this [ __ ] he's
the one in Ferren yeah that was one
store earlier alright well you got the
fairies
I got fairies you go try and kill a
guardian ya see that that's about
there's there's that filled fold and
close by right yeah I want my horse dumb
horse though so I'll go to that stable
that's nearby killer guardian
[Music]
oh we're back here there's a stable
nearby there's a stable nearby and then
I'll give me a horse so I can do that
slo-mo shot on a guardian
then yeah so that the plant still is to
get the stasis and then I'll go to the
castle and we'll see
oh I can do this
I mean their girder that dumb thing off
your face it's stupid rock it's part of
who I am
oh that's where although they're all
there do it up
you don't need bust off he'll just
complicate things
dude this is a guardian party there's
one there's two great yeah line down
here oh good there's a path oh wait
Stables up there no it's up it's like
right here pass this man here I don't
like this Oh shield shield bash it you
got it
don't you do you got 7 minutes left
got a couple all you got you got
Guardian arrows oh my got a guardian
arrow okay you're right
it's to homeroom wandering around I
don't want them both to come at me I
only have two arrows I think of one now
don't you should I go this one yeah
maybe land over there or something
frickin raining Wow a little sure
there's a little low give me a car
cor cor cor cor yeah there's one dole
two more two more if I have one arrow
left
you got your shields though those I mean
those ancient arrows did spawn back in
the castle oh yeah
might as well search this guy's gotta
have a horrible
[Music]
which I could climb this wings having a
hard time doing so now there we go
core
yeah one more I say go for it and the
episode by going for one with your
shield reflect deflect are there any
more Guardians walking around but it
takes like two three hits wait what yeah
it's not one hit only on a turret is it
one hit oh you oh you could do three
hits I'm scared
well I also have bomb arrows yeah oh but
it's raining so they won't explode Oh
either either these hurts should turn on
yeah I don't and I have an attack up so
I could be good you go stasis ready for
the next episode
yeah there should be another Walker will
turrets drop cores though I know I got I
don't I can't really like
how about I go to I mean they'll spawn
so what if I go to I'm good here I've
exhausted what I can so what if I go
back to here and end it on that one
guardian
I was bomb arrow and I'll do an attack
up and I'll just bomb ever the [ __ ] out
of his face which Guardian which the one
earlier in the stream that I went
against oh right got those bow cob and
screwed things up messed up by book
goblins yeah and I should have stasis
and it would be good cool okay I mean
hopefully he drops yeah if not you could
just go to the castle around the castle
yeah I'll go for another one in the
field kind of sucks cuz like there's so
many Guardians I don't want to like a
whole bunch to see me
oh you know the horse
please take bot stall look at that idiot
oh my my says my bond is match yeah mi
got a surprising surprise see so he
really is just dumb yeah what do you say
your horse isn't magic yeah we know
oh this is good stuff right here it's
great he's do you think how close they
are to a just a freaking terrorizing
spider bot like this peaceful little
stable and they go like could kill him
at any 100 yards away is just like
freaking horrifying machinery horrifying
thing well it wasn't him it was the book
goblins it was that lets do I might lure
him away I'm gonna eat nothing let me
see what I just do
just one dose for Commons see me see me
see me see me look over here I saw the
book problem right there - oh yeah I
mean screw it I'll just put this one
right right here yeah yeah I'm just
really surprised your bond with him is
that max well maybe I mean it's that max
doesn't mean it's good that's just the
highest bond you can have a bot stall
there's one right there is alright but
stall do you meet the attack up I'm
gonna wait and see what a bomber will do
this guy
all youth attack up
yeah yeah yeah yeah Oh what happened
your legs buddy when I worked out
oh that doesn't know what there you go
dope there's a good use of that sword
all right we good damn it all right well
what you did I don't think we know I
don't think got to all right let's go
everyone Guardian hunting
yeah that other one didn't have Bo
Cobbins be a lot easier there's another
one to the right but like by the ranch
here but guys that Loman ranch or no
that's farther away there's there's
another one of these guys that has like
bunch of Oh columns with them as well
hi look he loves it such a satisfying
sound effect oh yeah nice core core core
core
come on core damn it you [ __ ] I could do
that horse back - OH
there's forest so you technically
survive for an hour but I devil at their
core this is the wall now isn't it yeah
I got turrets working its time there
there's another one don't want to get
two on me there's anything just get in
so [ __ ] [ __ ]
almost learned this one away oh thanks
gonna blow himself up but stall Jesus
iiiii hello yeah she's like skin oh
there you go
oh my god there you go
can smash in the ground it's kind of
going through weapons here that's worth
it though for the stasis
you better have a core on you POS core
core core core core core core core damn
it why don't this other ones have been
in collar god I did next one's got to
have it I mean I don't know surely not
like take but try not like mess up their
legs cause the Guardian arrow that was
the only common thing that you yeah good
job deflecting his oh interesting I
never knew the pacing of the song is
slower for I guess the threat level of
the Guardian
no I don't like any of this I'm just
gonna leave there's one - yeah what a
guy's still going
doesn't range yeah it definitely got
faster
no you didn't get his I wait I didn't
get you
goddamn hell
nice core yes yes it is uh uh okay they
really made you fight for that laughs
obviously right that guy's like alright
alright dude you were in that one you
want to start next up so if I go into a
hottie no then sure you could probably
work too uh yeah okay cool sweet I'd say
successful overall up so next I guess
next time we're going to style Knox
keeping it a shield yep it's finally
coming cool cool
sweet thanks well thanks everybody for
joining every Thursday we published
great hoppers show where we put
permadeath in every game Rob is getting
I mean we said sometimes the plant
different plants come up but it seems
like we're getting toward the end so
we'll yeah I think no matter what we'll
be fighting for the Hylian Shield next
time against that giant skeleton style
box so that'll be interesting it will
happen like sooner than later thanks
everybody who's been commenting in
giving us tips and also especially
recommending future games for the series
because that's always really helpful and
fun to think about because as you can
see we are running out of games for the
first list or so but again thank you for
joining will update that so you you
survived like exactly five hours now I
think yeah like exactly cool all right
that's the record still but we'll be
back next week with more grave hoppers
we'll see you then
so yes okay